Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my marvel moon knight video about why
none of the three people who we saw snapped the
infinity gauntlet recently didn't see any of the
marvel gods before they did it or after they did
it despite the fact that the gods of the mcu are
crazy powerful cosmic beings it also explains why
christian bale's gorr the godbutcher is killing
all the marvel gods of the mcu now in present day
after the last snap where everyone came back and
how he's able to do that if you're brand new to
the channel moon knight episodes are starting this
week i will be doing episode videos for everything
the way i always do we're doing a giveaway for
disney plus memberships all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and post your favorite
moon knight trailer moment on the video but during
the moon knight series we're going to learn a lot
more about a certain order of the gods in the
marvel universe they're all very powerful but
just like every being that exists they're governed
by certain rules about how they exist how their
powers work and what they can do khonshu is the
egyptian moon god he's also the god of vengeance
in the mcu he's just one of the first major ones
that we're going to meet during the moon knight
episodes he's nuts he's going to be voiced by
f murray abraham it's going to be a lot of fun
but just to explain how gods exist in the mcu like
legit gods because you have people like thor odin
hela for instance who are also lesser gods of the
mcu even though not all asgardians are like them
with that kind of power the eternal movie also
showed that eternals think of the celestials
as gods except they're actually more like highly
advanced cosmic beings so if you're talking about
mcu power scaling you have very powerful cosmic
characters and you have legit gods sometimes
powerful cosmic characters can become lesser gods
and sometimes lesser gods can be less powerful
than some cosmic characters there is a one above
all a one true god capital g god who you never see
because he's way too powerful also explain why in
a second too important distinction too pretty much
all the gods that you would ever meet or see
in the marvel tv show or movies the actual gods
are really just lesser g gods different groups of
gods that are based on different cultures around
the universe are called different pantheons
like there's a pantheon of egyptian gods that
khonshu is part of we're going to meet during the
moonite episodes typically each group of gods are
only worried about their original universe that
they came from or their pantheon like gods could
theoretically travel the multiverse but their
power would work a little bit differently in other
universes and they wouldn't be nearly as powerful
outside their original universe which is the real
reason why you don't see a bunch of them just
traveling all over the multiverse all the time
and for the most part each universe that contains
the same type of pantheon even though there might
be small differences contains their own version of
a god so for instance there are many thor's in the
multiverse there are only a couple really powerful
cosmic characters and one true god that exists
for the entire multiverse like there's one living
tribunal he's a powerful cosmic character there's
one cosmos which sort of represents the living
entity that is the entire multiverse and there's
one capital g god for the entire multiverse but
probably the most important difference between
those lesser gods and the cosmic characters like
the celestials who are very very powerful and
powerful than most of the other gods is that a
god's power level is directly tied to the faith
in the numbers of their worshipers if more people
started worshiping a certain god over others that
god would become the most powerful god of the mcu
way more powerful than they currently are like a
god could become powerful enough to challenge
the celestials characters like thor odin and
hela are also basically people who start out as
cosmic characters who are then able to transition
through their actions trials artifacts that they
contain in their faith from their own people over
time to become actual lesser gods i'll explain how
that works too because other characters can do it
odin for instance did not start out being a god he
started out being a very powerful cosmic character
and through his actions became a god then
passed that god level power to his children
quick thor history lesson asgardian history lesson
odin actually comes from the aesir which is this
original cosmic race made up of part of the
asgardians odin's grandfather buri was king
of the aesir people he passed on the crown to
his son bore when he became king boer's brother
rebelled and went to the planet vanaheim and
established his own race of people they fight
a bunch of civil wars between their people and
eventually they declare peace and bore says that
what's going to happen is that when his son odin
becomes king he's going to marry the daughter of
his brother who they've been warring with named
frigga and when they get married that's going to
be their peace treaty they're going to leave and
form a different kingdom called asgard so to make
a star trek reference the creation of asgard was
sort of like the vulcans in the romulans coming
back together to form a single people while that
was happening he performed enough special cosmic
trials gained enough artifacts and gained the
faith like the collective faith of his people
who basically minted him a new god it just
made him more and more powerful and then
eventually when thor and hello were born
his natural children he biologically passed
that god tear power to them that's why every
single asgardian isn't as powerful as they are
so powerful enough characters can become lesser
gods even if they didn't start out that way and
gods can have children biologically like anyone
else and pass their power to them that way too
the other way to become a lesser god in the mcu
is through the collective unconscious of a large
enough group of people believing in you a massive
enough group of people can come together and will
something powerful enough into existence
essentially giving it power through the
power of their belief that's how the man gog
comes into existence and is powerful enough to
kill marvel gods it's also a thor based character
maybe they'll use it at some point in the movies
if everyone stops believing in a god because they
draw all their power from their collective faith
of their people their natural power level will
grow much weaker it's kind of like that with
konchu like khonshu does have legit power he's a
legit god but nobody really cares about khonshu
in the mcu right now so he's less powerful than
he used to be you can kill gods like you kill
any other mcu character except usually they're so
powerful that when legit gods die what happens to
their body their innate godly energy is dictated
by the rules of their faith and remember there are
a lot of just regular powerful cosmic characters
out there who are more powerful than legit gods
so being so powerful gods of course would want
to stop thanos from erasing half of all life
it effectively erased half their followers cutting
half of their power source you'd think that they
would do something during avengers infinity war
in avengers endgame also none of the people who
snapped the infinity gauntlet saw versions of
other gods before they snapped the gauntlet and
after they did in the soul world now thor was
there he is kind of a lesser god in the mcu so
technically a version of a god was there for these
infinity gauntlet snaps but you would think that
even more powerful cosmic characters would show
up to stop thanos from doing what he's doing there
are a couple important reasons why really powerful
legit marvel gods did not show up to either stop
or help characters while these were all happening
one probably the biggest reason is that all legit
gods of the mcu are extremely selfish and
even though they can barely care about their
own followers the vast majority of them don't
ever really pay attention to people from other
cultures and most of them aren't even powerful
enough to actually do anything most of them are
just concerned with their primary ordained
specific tasks that they're given by their
followers and they aren't really thinking about
what's happening across the universe or they don't
care about what's happening across the universe
one of the reasons why they do things this way
why the gods act this way is because if all the
gods of the scrolls for instance started messing
with the gods from the nine realms all those gods
would start fighting a war killing most of them so
each of them mostly stick to their own cultures
just to avoid open conflict amongst all the gods
two none of the people who snapped the infinity
gauntlet recently actually believe in a version of
any legit god if you think about it like iron man
and the hulk for instance are such hardcore team
science bros they are effectively atheists they
believe in powerful cosmic characters like thor
they've seen thor's power they've seen other
really powerful cosmic characters do unbelievably
powerful things but because they're so smart
they're so learned and they believe in science
so much they rationalize everything as the
acts of powerful cosmic forces not legit gods
god thanos is an eternal from the planet titan
he's super old like he understands even more
about how the universe works in his history in
the mcu god level characters then iron man and
thor would he's also a little older than thor
but he's younger than odin like he thinks what
he's doing is so important he thinks of himself as
god like balancing everything in the universe but
he's also kind of an atheist too not a really
devout person remember a lot of the power of
legit little g gods comes from the faith of their
followers so if all of them had actually believed
that thor was a real god and they had faith
in him like legit faith in him thor would have
actually become a little bit more powerful and
probably been able to stop thanos but because
the infinity gauntlet makes thanos for instance
so much more powerful as a cosmic character than
a lot of the other legit little g gods and
he believes that thor is not an actual god
thor's a little bit weaker and he's actually way
more powerful in none of the relevant legit gods
of the mcu who actually do have god-given power
and faith from their followers in the mcu belong
to pantheons that those characters believe in
none of those gods would have a special connection
to those three characters so most of them didn't
even try to stop thanos and thor for instance just
wasn't powerful enough to stop thanos and
three last reason this is also important
even though a lot of marvel gods govern what
happens to souls after they die talking more about
moon knight the mcu gods wouldn't some of them
have seen versions of gods after they had died
that was basically what happened after each
person snapped the infinity gauntlet they snap it
and it's such a powerful cosmic act that they
die briefly some of them are powerful enough to
survive but for a brief second they do die some of
them stay dead though like iron man talking about
moon knight the mcu gods anubis for instance is
a god who governs over the afterlife the reason
why thanos iron man and hook didn't see anyone
from conscious egyptian pantheon even though some
of them do govern over what happens to you after
you die is that after they did snap the infinity
gauntlet they went directly to the soul world even
though they didn't show that for the hulk the same
thing happened for him that happened for thanos
and iron man it's kind of like a pocket dimension
inside the infinity stone itself in all those mcu
gods that i'm talking about don't exist inside
the soul stone the same way and they don't have
power inside there like i said outside of their
original universe their original dimension they
have way less power conscious and his pantheon
in the moonlight series for instance are trapped
in a pocket dimension if they were able to somehow
physically enter the main mcu universe they'd be
way more powerful but only the soul stone has its
own special pocket dimension called the soul world
and it's a place that saves a copy of people's
souls under certain circumstances so it doesn't
save every single soul from every single person
who dies and when you die and enter the soul world
it also shows you a mental representation based on
your own experiences so that's why thanos sees
this young version of gamora in the shrine here
that looks like the one from her home planet and
when iron man and the hulk entered the soul world
it would have looked a little bit different for
each of them so as powerful as legit gods can be
in the mcu for instance thor good example they're
actually not as powerful as you think and most of
them are afraid of each other and starting a war
on that cosmic level so that's how gorr the god
butcher getting to that takes advantage of them
and is able to go around killing so many of the
mcu gods he's a normal character who's able to
attain an incredibly powerful cosmic artifact
the necro sword that makes him way more powerful
than most of the lesser gods of the mcu that's one
of the reasons why a lot of really powerful lesser
marvel gods don't do anything about the celestials
because they are really really powerful cosmic
level characters it's similar to the reason why
the one true god capital g god for the entire
multiverse allows things like this to happen
in different universes so essentially he
doesn't really get involved in or care
what happens to each universe it's like saying
that the lake does not care about the actual fish
if you've ever read the berserk manga it's kind of
like the god hand like the collective unconscious
creates the idea of evil and then the idea of evil
creates the god hand it just tells them do what
you would will this is the will of the collective
unconscious of the people this is what they want
just go do whatever you feel like doing so that's
why a lot of really bad things are allowed to
happen inside the mcu and none of the powerful
enough gods do anything about it it's also the
same reason that gorr the god butcher blames them
for being terrible gods like you're terrible as
a god no matter how powerful you are you're
not going to help us so i'm going to kill you
that's why it's so useful that we're going to
learn about what's going on with konchu and how he
works his pantheon of gods before we see the thor
love and thunder trailer and we see gorr of the
god butcher going around killing all these marvel
gods like khonshu for instance would be on gorr's
list but my full moonite episode 1 video will
post next on wednesday just like normal there'll
be new episodes every week if you have any
questions just leave them in the comments below
congratulations to the giveaway winner for my
last video jonathan booker please email me on
the about page of my channel so i can get your
contact details everyone click here for my new
moon knight trailer video and learn what's
going on with doctor strange during the moon
knight episodes and click here to learn more
about moon knight's battle with the actual gods
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!